[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIDYA NAGARAJAN: So first, by a
show of hands, how many of you
have heard about Cloud Identity?
I know you're all here.
How many of you think that
G Suite is Cloud Identity?
OK, good.
How many of you have heard
of the term BeyondCorp.
OK, great.
And how many of you think
that device management
is a part of Cloud Identity?
OK, great.
OK.
I hope you'll find the
session today interesting.
So we'll see.
So we'll cover the following
topics this afternoon--
Woodstock with an overview
of Cloud Identity.
We'll go over the
various features,
talk about the roadmap, go
over some exciting demos.
Colin will talk about
their Cloud Identity
experience and
journey at Essence
and we'll tie all this together.
And at the end, we will
have some time for Q&A.
So it's pretty amazing to see
how the generation of today
has got vastly different
expectations from what
I had growing up.
So technology has come a really
long way in the last 20 years.
There was a time when
my computer at work
was a lot better than
what I had at home,
and my internet
connectivity at work
was way better than
what I had at home.
And in fact, I
would come to work,
and I could only access data
within my office boundaries,
because I knew no better.
Today's generation,
on the contrary,
expects way more flexibility.
They want to be
able to access data
from anywhere, from any device.
And the workspace
as we know it is
going through a massive
digital transformation
just to support their needs.
And you, as IT decision
makers, are at the forefront,
making all this happen.
And identity and
access management
is front and center
of this revolution.
So we're living
in a perimeterless
or an edgeless world, a world
in which the enterprise security
perimeter is no longer
your office front door.
But instead, it is elastic,
and it's dispersed.
And it's wrapped around
each user and each device.
And everything is
based on context.
And your users are not
just your employees.
But now they are your vendors,
they're your contractors,
they're your customers.
And all of these different
people have different needs,
and they need to access
different information,
different applications,
from different places,
and from different devices.
So clearly, a different
approach to identity and access
management is critical
and important.
Existing approaches are very
complex, very time consuming,
and very cumbersome.
They were built for
the on-premise world,
and they are not optimized for
today's cloud-forward world.
So with more users requesting
access for more information
and from more devices
than ever before,
IT teams struggle with a
complex network of managing
applications, devices, users.
And shadow IT is also a
huge problem in this space.
But therein also
lies our opportunity.
So in 2011, Google came
up with a new model
of defining access
management, which
is what we call as BeyondCorp.
It's a new enterprise
security model
which started as an
internal Google initiative
to enable every employee
to be able to work
from untrusted networks without
the use of a traditional VPN.
BeyondCorp typically
shifts the access
controls from that of
the network perimeter
to that of the application.
It's all around each user
and each device, thereby
allowing employees to work
securely from any location.
So Cloud Identity helps bring
the BeyondCorp provision
to your organization.
It is designed around the core
pillars of being simple, smart,
and secure.
So people, devices,
applications, directory,
and extensible APIs are
all first class citizens,
managed within a unified,
single pane of glass.
People, devices, and context
is your new security perimeter.
So policies are
defined, and they're
enforced, to
control access based
on the user's identity and
the context of that request.
So while Cloud Identity
helps you as an organization
to move towards
the cloud, we also
want to make sure we meet the
organization where they are
in their cloud
journey by supporting
your on-premise identity and
access management systems.
So in the next section,
we'll talk about some
of the key features
of Cloud Identity,
and we'll also go
over the roadmap.
But I want you to remember
that Cloud Identity enjoys
the following key
differentiators--
first and foremost,
Cloud Identity
enjoys Google grade security.
You can control access
to SaaS applications.
And for strong,
multi-factor authentication,
protect your users and accounts,
get automatic protections
against hijacking with
machine learning data
from Google services.
And above all, we ensure
that everything is simple.
It's simple not just for
the IT administrator,
but also for the end user.
And it's about meeting you
where you are in your journey.
And we believe in supporting
your hybrid identity story.
So let's first talk
about the people.
With Cloud Identity, enterprises
can automatically provision
accounts into Google's Cloud
Directory using APIs or using
our tool called the Google
Cloud Directory Sync.
Accounts can also be
automatically provisioned
into third party systems
using a feature called
auto provisioning.
And that ensures both
end user as well as
administrative convenience, and
also has security compliance.
Google protects all
Cloud Identity accounts
against account takeover,
compromise, or hijacking
through the use of
machine learning data
from over eight services
with over one billion
plus 30-day active users.
So Cloud Identity
offers multiple options
to protect user accounts
with strong authentication
methods which we call
2-step verification.
That includes push
notifications,
one-time passwords,
password alerts, and so on.
And further, as awareness
of potential vulnerabilities
associated with telephony
options like SMS or voice codes
has increased, we also provide
admins with the ability--
we give them the choice--
to disable these telephony
options like SMS or voice codes
if they so choose or desire as
a 2SV method for their users.
We've also long advocated
the use of security keys
as the strongest and the
most phishing-resistant
authentication method
for high-value users.
Customers have long told us
that it can be hard to source
and roll out security keys.
So we have the
Titan Security Key,
which is a FIDO-based
security SKI that
includes firmware that has been
developed by Google to verify
its integrity.
It's available through
the Google Store,
but it's rolling out in
other regions very soon.
So we'd also like to announce
that you can use your Android
phone now as a security key.
This is a feature that's
available in beta.
And this offers both strongest
protection and authentication
for your users, while offers
convenience for the users.
Because now, it's a
one-time enrollment process.
There is no additional
hardware or apps required,
and you get that strong
authentication and protection
for your high value users.
Cloud Identity also comes
with the Security Center
that provides controls from
prevention t detection,
to remediation.
So admins can manage and
improve their security posture
within the organization.
For example, they can get
proactive phishing protection.
They can get actionable security
insights through the dashboard,
for example, phishing risks.
And they can diagnose, triage,
and resolve security incidents
through the investigation tool.
We're excited to announce
that Cloud Identity will now
allow integration
with third party HRIS
systems such as BambooHR,
ADP, Ultimate Pro, and Namely,
to enable automated user
lifecycle management.
And this will be generally
available in the summer.
And Shivani will now
give a quick peek
at what this will look like.
SHIVANI SINHA: Hello, everyone.
So here is a quick peek
at what this integration
is going to look like.
Let's say your
company uses BambooHR
for storing employee
information,
and now your IP admin wants to
sync this employee information
from BambooHR to Cloud Identity.
The way they can do
that is by accessing
the external directory
section of the admin console.
Here, you can add your
BambooHR external directory.
When you click on Add,
you get to this page
where you can add some brief
information about BambooHR.
As you can see, we need to also
add a service account, Now,
this service account
is going to be
used to sync the employee
information from BambooHR
to Cloud Identity.
When you click on Add
Directory, a SCIM endpoint URL
is generated, and now you need
to copy this endpoint URL,
and paste it into
BambooHR setup page.
Now, that syncs the employee
information from BambooHR
to Cloud Identity.
Once the sync is setup, any
time you add, modify, or delete
a user in BambooHR, this
information gets automatically
updated in Cloud Identity,
and your company no longer
needs to maintain any manual
sync between these two systems.
VIDYA NAGARAJAN: OK, great.
So now, let's talk
about applications.
So we first spoke
about people, now,
let's talk about applications.
Cloud Identity comes
with a very rich catalog
of thousands of federated
apps that support SAML as well
as OIDC standards.
In addition, we're
happy to announce
that Cloud Identity
will also support
password-based single sign-on
into those applications that
do not support the
federated standards.
This will be generally
available end of the summer.
And this was a key
feature that was
a part of our VDM acquisition.
Also coming soon is
a new end user hub
where users can quickly
access all of their apps
from one single place.
A key tenet of Cloud
Identity is the ability
to meet organizations where
they are in their cloud journey.
While the adoption of SaaS
apps continues to grow,
many businesses still rely on
traditional, legacy on-premise
LDAP-based applications.
So Secure LDAP in
Cloud Identity allows
you to use a single
access management
platform to access
both your SaaS
as well as your on-premise
LDAP applications.
So what this means
is that admins
can manage both the SaaS as
well as your on-premise LDAP
applications from one
single control plane.
And end users can use the same
Cloud Identity credentials
and can log into
both the SaaS as well
as on-prem applications.
So we have several partners
that are integrating with Secure
LDAP today, and we're happy
to announce our latest
entrant to the Cloud, GitLab.
So now, let's see
this in action.
SHIVANI SINHA: Thank you, Vidya.
So let's see a demo
of Secure LDAP.
Now, let's say your company
uses GitLab to write and manage
code.
And now, your admin
wants to configure
Secure LDAP with GitLab
so your engineering
team can log in to GitLab
using their Cloud Identity
credentials.
The way, this is going
to work is the admin
has to first go to the LDAP
section of the Admin console,
as you can see on the screen.
Now, you can add
a new LDAP client
by clicking on Add Client.
Let us give our
LDAP client a name.
Let's call it GitLab.
You can add a description
if you want to,
but for now, I'm
going to skip it.
Let's click on Continue.
Now, this takes me to the
access permissions page,
where I can configure access
permissions for my GitLab LDAP
client.
I can figure out how much
of my directory information
this client should
be able to access.
For example, I can
click on entire domain
if all my employees should be
able to log in and to GitLab,
or I can select a specific OU.
Now, if I click
on Edit, I can see
that I can select
the Engineering
OU, because only my engineers
need to write code in GitLab.
Let's hit Save.
When I scroll down,
I can also select
what user and group
information the client
should be able to get access to.
Let's click on Add, and
click on Engineering,
because the client should only
be able to access Engineering.
Let's allow the client to
read group information.
And now, click on
Add LDAP Client.
Now, this should
generate a certificate.
You need to now download
this certificate
and then upload the certificate
to your LDAP client.
You can do so for GitLab by
following this public document
that GitLab has published.
By reading the instructions in
the Configuring GitLab section,
you can now upload
your certificate
and set that sync between
GitLab and Cloud Identity.
Once this is done, what
it means for employees
is your engineering team can
now use their Cloud Identity
credentials to log in to GitLab.
And your admin can now use
the same admin console,
the same single pane of
glass, to both manage
your SaaS applications and
your on-prem applications.
[APPLAUSE]
VIDYA NAGARAJAN:
Thanks, Shivani.
Now, let's talk about devices.
So we spoke about people,
we spoke about applications,
and now let's talk
about devices.
So Cloud Identity
helps organizations
to enforce policies consistently
across multiple endpoints,
whether it's iOS,
Android, or Chrome.
We're happy to
announce that we now
have more than 55 million
30-day devices under management.
So admins can enforce
screen locks or passcodes
to secure devices.
They can wipe corporate data
on devices, view and search
for devices, export details.
All of this can be done
with basic device management
functionality without the need
of an installed agent, which
is a very powerful
functionality to secure
your devices while keeping
your users productive.
Admins can whitelist
apps, they can separate
your work and personal
data, distribute apps,
and, lastly, admins can
audit devices, set up rules
to manage these
devices at scale.
So we spoke about BeyondCorp
at the start of the session.
BeyondCorp allows a
new way of working
in a perimeterless
or an edgeless world,
where everything is
based on context.
It's based on the user's
identity and the context
of that originating request.
So the components in
the BeyondCorp model
are user trust--
you have device trust.
You have the context.
So you have a rules engine which
actually then processes access
to these resources
based on the context--
what is the IP address,
what is the location, what
is the time, session, so on.
And all of these
components are actually
powered by different assets
in the Google Cloud stack.
And the assets include
Cloud Identity,
there is something called
endpoint verification,
the Google front end,
access context manager,
and then you have the
different enforcement points,
like whether it's Google IAP.
There is IAM, Cloud Identity,
VPC Service Controls,
and so on.
We're happy to announce
that context-aware access is
generally available
for Cloud IAP.
And it's now in open
beta for G Suite,
so please go try it out
and see this in action.
Shivani.
SHIVANI SINHA: Thank you, Vidya.
Now, I'm going to demo
context-aware access.
So let's say your company has
a lot of confidential files
stored in Google Drive.
And now, your IT Admin
wants to make sure
that employees can only
access Google Drive from corp
network--
so only when you're
in your workplace.
And your IT admin
doesn't care about Gmail.
They always want
you to check Gmail
so you're up-to-date
with your emails,
and so they don't
mind if you can check
your email outside of work
So let's see this in action.
How does your IT admin set
up such a security policy?
Your IT admin can set
up the security policy
from the context-aware access
page of the Admin console.
Now, I have already set
this policy up for you,
so I'm going to show
you how this was set up.
If I click on the
Access level, I
can see a policy
called corp IP address.
Now, if I click on
Assign Access Levels,
I can see to whom this
access level was assigned.
So when I click
on this section, I
can see that it
was assigned to me.
Now, I'm present in the
legal organization unit.
So when I click on the
legal organization unit,
I can scroll down and see that
the corp IP address access
level was assigned
to Drive and Docs.
Now, this means that I
won't be able to access
Drive and Docs outside of work.
However, you can also see that
it's not assigned to Gmail.
So I should be able to
access Gmail outside of work.
So let's see this in action.
Well, where am I?
I'm in a hotel.
I'm clearly not in
a Google building,
so I should be able
to access Gmail,
but I shouldn't be
able to access Drive.
So if I try to access Gmail.
Yay, I can access Gmail.
And if I try to access
Drive, I shouldn't
be able to access Drive.
There you see, I
don't have access.
Now, let me walk you
through how you can set up
more such security policies.
You can set up a security
policy by going here, and then
creating a new access
level, and then assigning
that access level in
the second section
to a specific organization
unit, your entire domain,
and to a particular application.
So let's go ahead and
create a new access level.
Let's say I'm the IT admin
of your organization,
and I don't want you
to access Google Drive
from outside your
corporate device.
So if you're using
your personal laptop,
I don't want you to be
able to access Google Drive
from your personal laptop.
The way I can do that is by
creating a new access level.
Let's give it a name--
Corporate device only.
When I click on Continue, I
can now set up some conditions.
When I click on Attribute, I
want to select Device policy,
because the is
related to devices.
I can click on Yes
for whether the device
should have a password
to add more enforcements.
I can add other
restrictions too,
such as I can enforce
a minimum macOS version
or a minimum Chrome OS version.
Now, I need to select Required
under corporate owned device.
I can add other conditions and
they'll all get compounded.
But for now, I'll
keep it simple,
and I'll click on
Create Access Level
to create this access level.
Now, I can see that in
addition to corp IP address
and the other access
levels that are here,
I have the Corporate device
only access level created.
I can assign this newly
created access level
to whichever application
that I want to assign it to.
Let's assign it to me again--
because other people are
probably demoing with
the same customer,
so I don't want to break them--
and assign it to Drive and Docs.
I can compound
multiple access levels.
So I already have the
corp IP address access
level assigned to me.
I can also click on Corporate
device only and hit Save.
So that's how you
create new access levels
and assign these access levels
to whichever organization unit
you want to.
If you want to assign it
to your entire domain,
you can click on
the entire domain.
Now, I'm going to hand it
off to Colin from Essence
to talk about his experiences
using Cloud Identity.
COLIN MCCARTHY: There we go.
Thank you.
I knew there'd be some glitch.
And the other
glitch you can see,
we've got the status bar on the
screen, which we can't work out
why it's there.
But I'm from Essence.
I'm Colin McCarthy.
I'm the VP for global IT.
I've been with the company
for 10 years, nine years,
started in 2010 when it was a
lot simpler time, where we just
had one office and
60 users, and one
app that we would log
into with single sign-on
with SAML-based application.
But I wanted to talk to you
about our growth, our journey
using G Suite,
and how we've been
using Cloud Identity and the
context-aware access policy
that we've been testing
for the last few months
and deployed in North America
and also recently in London.
So Essence, of course, has been
a longtime user of Google Apps.
We started with Google
Apps Business in 2009.
And being very much a
cloud-based company,
that has allowed us to
have a lot of growth,
where in the last nine years
we've grown to 60 offices--
sorry, 19 offices and 1,800
users around the world.
We've also deployed a lot of
the Cloud Identity security
products that have been released
over the last few years--
MFA in 2013, and also Mobile
Device Management in 2014.
A show of hands, how many people
have got MFA and Mobile Device
Management on their
Android and iOS devices?
I should see every hand go up.
If somebody is hand
hasn't gone up,
I'm sure you're a
little bit embarrassed.
If you are using G Suite
and Cloud Identity,
you certainly should
have MFA and also
Mobile Device
Management deployed
across your enterprise.
There are, obviously,
a number of challenges
that we have with G Suite.
G Suite is brilliant.
You can access it in any
location, on any device.
And that's one of the
challenges from accessing it
from any location in any device.
Over the last few
years, I've discovered
and seen a lot more stringent
security requirements coming
down from vendors and
clients, where in 2011, 2012,
maybe if you had a new
client they would ask you
40 security questions.
Last year, the
security audits that we
would get from clients, and
vendors, and other suppliers
would have 200 to 400
different security questions.
So everybody has very much
a security-focused mindset,
and thankfully
with Cloud Identity
and context-aware
access, you now
have the ability
to have confidence
that you're able to enforce
those corporate policies
across any device that's
accessing your data.
One of the barriers for
deploying any new security
feature is, of course, making
it seamless for the end user.
Because the last thing you
want to do is deploy security
but then inhibit
and make working
with your corporate technology
more of a hindrance to your end
users.
Because if they don't
like that technology
or if it requires too much
of a disruption on the way
that they work, they're
naturally going to bypass that,
and they'll find other ways
of working, which is obviously
how shadow IT has become
such a big corporate problem.
So with deploying any
new security feature,
it's all about
making it seamless
as possible for the end user.
And one of the good things
with context-aware access,
as it was shown, if it's
a corporate-owned machine,
you can upload all the
service or the serial numbers,
and take ownership
of those machines,
and apply the
policies so that you
know that your data is
secure, but it doesn't really
impact the end user whatsoever.
So the challenges that we have
solved with Cloud Identity--
with the BambooHR and
the HRIS integration,
we're going to very much
be able to streamline
our onboarding process and
also the off-boarding process,
making sure that accounts are
created at the right time,
people have the right access
to the right resources.
But also, when a
staff member leaves,
you can make sure that our
account is automatically
deprovisioned.
With Mobile Device
Management, we've
always been able to put
in security restrictions
or security policies on
Android and iOS devices.
Now, we can do those same
policies on Windows and Macs.
And also, with the improvement
in the account security,
we're able to disable
phone-based SMS and phone call
verification, and then
go to the security
key type concept of managing
the MFA for our users.
So some of the scenarios
that we've been able to solve
or could potentially solve
at Essence with context-aware
access--
and I'm sure this will be the
same for many organizations
here--
is if you do have temporary
workers in your organization,
you can specify that they
can only access applications
from corporate machines
inside your corporate office.
You could also make sure that
your full-time employees can
only access data from devices
that comply with your security
policy, which,
obviously, is going
to be an encrypted hard
disk and a password,
and as we shown, potentially,
a minimal level of OS.
It's very likely that
we will at some point
disallow the use of Windows 7.
I only have one user in New
York at the moment who's
still using Windows 7 at home.
I've given her notice that
she needs to upgrade and move
to Windows 10.
It's the same for any
of the macOS versions
that people might be
running with that belief
that, oh, macOS
is secure, I don't
need to update my OS from 2014.
So you do have the ability to
do those OS-level restrictions.
The other thing you
can do is you can also,
as the product
develops, we're going
to be able to do
time-based restrictions.
So you can make sure
that your employees,
dependent on their
role, are only
able to access applications
through business hours,
or so they all give you
alerts or do restrictions
on accessing data from
high-risk locations,
so that you know that if your
New York employees aren't going
to be traveling to
China, then there's
no reason why their
account should be logging
in on China or Slovakia or any
other country around the world.
Also, you can specify
that employees that
are leaving your
company, maybe you,
as part of the
off-boarding process,
maybe you say that they can only
access their corporate network
from inside the
corporate office.
It's just a good security
way that with this you
can manage the onboarding
and the off-boarding process.
So how did we deploy it?
This was, for us
and my colleagues,
was probably the
smoothest, largest
deployment that we have done
to date, over all of our years.
Everybody, I'm assuming,
has the ability
to push out an application to
their corporate end devices,
whether you're using
Jamf or Microsoft Intune.
So we pushed out the native
helper that's required.
I enforced foreseeing the
Chrome extension to be installed
for everybody's profile.
But what we did before we
did all of those, I guess,
the technical side of it,
we spent a lot of time
on the human side of it
and made sure that we
had executive buy-in.
The COO was on-board
with the changes
that we were going to make.
We alerted all of
the regional office
leads that we were
going to be pushing
this out to their staff.
And then we also did a
series of emails or notices
on our internal system, telling
users what was going to happen.
And we also educated our
support staff and told them,
this is the change that
we're going to be making,
these are probably
the issues that you're
going to come across.
And if you put out a good
documentation to your end users
about a change, you can
probably expect that 10% to 20%
of those users aren't going to
read or action those documents.
So if you have 500
users, your help desk
can expect to have between
50 and 100 users having
problems on any particular day.
And that's what my poor
colleagues in London
had on Monday, when we
enforced context-aware access.
We spend a lot of time
working with our end users.
I did a small trial.
I tested it on my test
account, got very familiar
with the application
and the policies that
could be enforced.
Then did it to four people,
did it to 20 people,
and then pushed it
out of 400 people.
And probably in the space of
about 10 days, did all of that,
and really honed
the communication
and created some
animated GIFs so they
could see the whole process.
And that was our
process through that.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
VIDYA NAGARAJAN:
Thank you, Colin.
OK.
So now, let's put
this all together
in terms of defining
what a typical customer
journey could look like.
So Acme Corp is a company
which has many of its IT Assets
on premise.
Many of their systems, their
devices, their print servers,
their VPN servers,
et cetera, are
integrated into Active
Directory for authentication
or for other identity needs.
Acme Corp's CIO has decided that
they want to move to the cloud
so that they can embrace
this BeyondCorp philosophy,
and they can make their
users and employees
way more productive, and work
securely so that they can work
from anywhere, from any device.
And also, it helps increase Acme
Corp's return on investment.
So first, to integrate
what with Cloud Apps,
Acme Corp Decides to replace
their on-premise SSO solution
with Cloud Identity.
So they use the tool called the
Google Cloud Directory Sync,
and that tool essentially syncs
information, users, groups,
and other metadata information
from Active Directory
into Google's Cloud Directory.
They also replace their
productivity suite
with G Suite.
Now, that they have successfully
integrated all their cloud apps
with Cloud Identity,
they start integrating
their legacy on-premise
LDAP-based applications,
using Cloud Identity's
Secure LDAP functionality
that we visited earlier.
They can also then
integrate their VPN servers
as part of their IT
infrastructure, Mac or Linux
devices with Secure
LDAP, and potentially
also manage all their
other Windows-type
of devices with Cloud
Identity in the future.
So now, you've heard quite
a bit this afternoon,
and you can see there's a
ton of great functionality
that is in the product.
And the good news is,
all of this functionality
is available for
one single license.
And many of you in this room
might be existing G Suite
customers, or you might be
using Google Cloud Platform,
and you might wonder,
how does licensing
work in such a situation?
So the good news is, Cloud
Identity's free functionality
is available or is built into G
Suite Basic and Business SKUs.
If you are a G Suite
Enterprise user,
the Cloud Identity
standalone product,
which we call as Cloud
Identity Premium,
is built into that product.
So as a customer, if you
want to use functionality
like context-aware access,
which Shivani demoed earlier,
you have the option of buying or
upgrading to G Suite Enterprise
or you could buy the standalone
Cloud Identity product
and use that alongside
your existing G Suite Basic
and Business subscriptions.
If you are using Google
Cloud Platform today,
you can sign up for
the free Cloud Identity
account as part of your regular
cloud onboarding experience.
However, if you require Premium
identity functionality--
for example, if you want session
management controls so that you
can actually control session
lengths for your different
accessing your cloud
admin console--
you would then need the
Cloud Identity Premium
product which you can
then add-on as an upgrade.
So in a nutshell, Cloud
Identity is a unified platform
to manage your people,
devices, and applications.
It enables the BeyondCorp
vision and allows your users
to be truly productive
but extremely secure,
with features like
context-aware access.
It increases productivity
with single sign-on
to thousands of applications,
both by supporting
federated standards
like SAML and Open IDC,
as well as password-based
SSO for those applications
that don't support the
federated standards.
It provides account
security with MFA,
as well as security keys--
security keys from outside
or the Titan security key
from Google.
And it very much
enables hybrid identity
and meets organizations where
they are in your current cloud
journey.
So this is either with the
help of tools like Secure LDAP
or directory sync tools like
the Google Cloud Directory Sync,
which syncs information
from your on-premise systems
to Google's Cloud Directory.
And again, all of
this is available
for a single subscription,
and you can sign up today
for a free trial.
So please do sign-up, and
let us know how it works out.
You can go to
cloud.google.com/identity
and check the product out for
yourself for a 14-day trial,
and give us your feedback.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]